[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires tout de suite voici les
titres de l'actualité on est morts avec
la découverte d'un métier devenu
essentiel pour nos sociétés celui
d'auxiliaire de vie avec le
vieillissement de la population les
besoins de recrutement sont importants
la rédaction de 8 mont blanc a suivi le
travail d'une professionnelle lors de
ses visites à reportage à suivre dès le
début de ce journal le retour des
patients dans les établissements de cure
thermale après deux ans de pandémie les
structures retrouve un public avide
d'activités et de soins comme nous le
montrera la rédaction devos télévision
dans un instant la faune et la flore
mise à l'honneur via la photographie
dans la somme des passionnés guidés par
des professionnels apprennent à
photographier des oiseaux en plein vol
de belles images à découvrir avec ueo
télé la chaîne du groupe la voix du nord
un concert les pieds et la tête dans
l'eau une expérience originale proposée
dans le sud ouest par l'ancien
guitariste de noir désir serge
teyssot-gay un concert pour se relaxer
grâce à des sons naturels par portage
enfin d'édition devient occitanie
ce fut l'un des sujets essentiels de la
campagne présidentielle le
vieillissement de la population la
tendance inexorable appel à une
transformation de nos pratiques parmi
les métiers d'avenir qui aideront à
répondre à la question du grand âge
celui des auxiliaires de vie ces femmes
et ces hommes dédient leur vie à nos
aînés et les accompagne dans leur
quotidien leur présence permet à
certains d'entre eux de continuer à
vivre à domicile et c'est une belle
chose il te rien lopez a passé une
matinée aux côtés d'une de ces
professionnels dans le bassin d'annecy
un reportage de huit mont-blanc
vous arrêtez la ligue 1 chaque jeudi
elodie accompagne madame rigaud au
marché la jeune femme est auxiliaire de
vie depuis près de 13 ans elle vient
tourner aide chaque jour à des personnes
âgées dans certains moments de leur
quotidien madame rigaud à 84 ans elle
vit seule dans son appartement
elodie passé un peu plus d'une heure
avec elle deux fois par semaine jusqu'à
présent je me débrouillais tout seul ce
canal dernière où je suis tombé j'ai une
petite fracture haleine donc chute au
point de vue mobilité je n'ai pu écouter
au bout d'un moment
je tangue mais dans la maison ça va bien
je ne prends pas la cas ne rien du tout
mais je suis contente d'avoir et le duc
et qui vient mais quand même et puis moi
pour moi c'est une compagnie aussi la
présence d'elodie bienveillante et
rassurante pour les familles est
indispensable pour madame durée à 88 ans
elle vit seule elle aussi elle est
atteinte de la maladie d'alzheimer ses
neuf enfants sont très présents mais ils
sont aussi très occupé ils ont donc fait
appel aux services d'elodie moi ça fait
cinq ans avec madame du rêve savez je
connais quoi là autant par contre que
elle connaît la ville s'est séparé c'est
ce que j'ai et twitter s'il apparaît
change on peut pas faire ce métier pour
élodie ce métier est une vocation
qu'elle exerce avec passion elle a été
recrutée par la maison petit fils une
entreprise spécialisée dans le service
d'aidé à domicile qui s'est installé à
annecy en 2016 sa devise s'occuper de
ses clients comme de ses propres grands
parents on a une exigence dans la
sélection des hawks un devis avec
lesquels on travaille
ça se matérialise par de l'expérience
minimum 3 ans et un diplôme
d'auxiliaire de vie ou d'être soignante
la plupart du temps mais également une
attitude terre qu'on va être attention
attentionné à l'attitude à la qualité
relationnelle que va pouvoir développer
le tir de vie au delà de l'expérience et
du diplôme voilà petit fils emploie une
cinquantaine d'auxiliaires dans le
bassin annécien elles interviennent
auprès de 250 familles l'entreprise
espère en recruter 35 nouvelles cette
année pour répondre à une demande
toujours en hausse
et puis chloé morin était l'invité de
l'émission face aux territoires sur tv5
monde de jeudi dernier la politologue
ancienne conseillère du premier ministre
est notamment revenu sur la campagne
présidentielle
écoutez ce qu'elle a dit comment faire
en sorte demain d'organiser la
participation réelle actif des
citoyennes et des citoyens à la vie
politique parce qu'on a l'impression
aujourd'hui que trop d'entre elles trop
d'entre eux sont spectateurs et non pas
acteur
je pense qu'il ya pas de réponse toute
faite mais la première chose pour
apporter une réponse et de poser la
question et le
grand problème du débat présidentiel
c'est qu'on n'a pas posé cette question
là et que la question démocratique
d'ailleurs elle est arrivée tout à la
fin du début du débat entre les deux
alors qu'elle est à mon avis première
est que je pense qu'on est capable de
dégager des compromis dans la société à
ces trans partisan sur justement la
nécessité de réengager les citoyens pour
voir où pour revoir face aux territoires
avec l'om aura rendez vous sur les sites
internet des partenaires de l'émission
c'est à dire ouest france nice matin et
vingt minutes le reste de l'actualité de
nos territoires marquée par le début des
vacances de pâques et le retour des
touristes depuis la fin des restrictions
liées aux qu'ovide un retour visible
jusque dans les établissements de cure
thermale dans les vosges vous allez le
voir les termes de balle et ben rouvrent
leurs portes depuis un mois
l'établissement reçoit entre 200 et 250
personnes par jour des curistes qui ont
modifié certains de leurs comportements
les réservations sont désormais plus
tardive reportage de thierry masson et
dan didier pour vosges télévision
après deux années pour le moins
compliquée en raison de la crise
sanitaire voire inexistantes en 2001 les
curistes ont enfin retrouvé le chemin de
la station thermale de balai bas l'une
des rares en france à être spécialisée
dans le traitement des maladies cardio
artérielle et rhumatologiques depuis le
21 mars dernier les portes de
l'établissement de santé ou le masque
reste malgré tout obligatoire ce sont
donc rouverte et pour certains d'entre
eux il y avait urgence à reprendre ou
entamer une cure rencontre des patients
alors notamment maladies cardio
artérielle alors qu'ils ont eu par
exemple un geste chirurgical qui peuvent
avoir
une période où ils sont un petit peu en
perte de confiance par rapport à leur
autonomie c'est urgent de les sortir de
la sédentarité c'est le cas de nathalie
venue de bretagne après un double
pontage et de l'arthrite au pied ce qui
me concerne c'est surtout tout ce qui
est cardio dans l'eau parce que
c'est beaucoup plus facile par rapport
aux articulations également est
également l'endurance mais modérée et au
niveau de l'arthrite les soins qu'on
nous donne sont vraiment bénéfique la
preuve j'ai amené mes antidouleur et
j'en ai pris que 2 si le centre semble
donc avoir retrouvé une bonne vitesse de
croisière il reste néanmoins difficile
de se projeter sur des chiffres de fin
de saison là cette année c'est plus
difficile dans le sens où ils vont
la réservation un mois un mois et demi
avant avant de venir une large palette
d'activités sentais comme un spa des
bains de boue la marche nordique la
sophrologie la musicothérapie ou
l'aquabike complète notamment l'offre de
l'établissement hors saison 15
permanents travaillent qu'ici que
viennent renforcer de mars à novembre
une trentaine de saisonniers
la relance du secteur de l'événementiel
est elle aussi en marche en martinique
le secteur recrute et se prépare pour la
période estivale pour répondre aux
besoins de main d'oeuvre les employeurs
font appel notamment à des lycéens en
rupture scolaire ils sont formés pour
monter des échafaudages et peuvent ainsi
se constituer une expérience en vue
d'une éventuelle embauche un reportage
de jean marc d'abreu pour vyas atv en
martinique
c'est en chantier grandeur nature pour
ces élèves du lycée de paul buisson
allée
la mise en place d'un échafaudage sur le
plateau sportif de la commune du carnet
à plusieurs mètres du sol ces apprentis
n'ont pas le droit à l'erreur de monter
chaque élément de la bonne façon bonne
condition physique attention motivation
à toute épreuve des pré-requis
indispensables pour réussir cette
mission
à leurs côtés des formateurs
expérimentés s'assure du respect des
règles de sécurité donne rendez vous
derrière tyson longe que plus attachés à
chaque moment de céder place des doigts
vous attachez mélo dans le vide on
enlève les noeuds parce qu'il est trop
tendue non là derrière ta main droite
n'ont pas encore transmettre son savoir
faire pour assurer la relève c'est aussi
l'objectif de classe régisseuse dans le
domaine du spectacle en plus on est
tombés sur des jeunes qui veulent
vraiment travailler c'est
c'est bien pour nous parce que c'est un
métier qui qui a pris de l'âge qui l'est
c'est un métier où les gens ont quitté
un petit peu le métier du fait du
confinement et du manque de travail donc
du coup c'est bien de voir qu'il ya des
gens qui vont arriver du derrière nous
et les professeurs ont encore une
dizaine de jours pour monter cette scène
qui devrait accueillir un festival de
hip hop d'ici le 24 avril prochain
des échafaudages island est recouverte
tout juste trois ans après son incendie
la cathédrale notre dame de paris est en
pleine restauration le chantier inédit
et gigantesque nécessite l'intervention
d'artisans et d'ouvriers de toute la
france parmi eux une scierie de la loire
l'entreprise locale a notamment produit
5000 call pour le chantier une fierté
bien sûr pour son géant est une
opportunité pour son activité un sujet
d'anthony vire peu long pour tl7 la
télévision de la loire
et bien ce que j'ai dans les mains c'est
les couacs eux qu'on a fourni pour la
cathédrale de paris et puis bah c'est
quoi ils sont faits pour mettre entre
les vous télé et là reboot en lamellé
collé qu'ils aient mis pour renforcer et
pour coincer en fait coincer c'est mais
pierre ce sont de simples morceaux de
bois d'une soixantaine de centimètres
et pourtant il était essentielle à la
sécurisation du chantier de notre dame
de paris et gilles durand a été contacté
par mail l'an dernier par un tailleur de
pierre qui s'activent sur le chantier et
une fois la surprise passée il a reçu
une commande de 5000 coin comme celui ci
une fierté mêlée a beaucoup d'humilité
mais orgueilleux on y flâne le travail
et puis surtout après moi comme suit
pratique à la sortie de l'église et ben
et à la conviction du wargame libre mais
c'est bien ce que tu as fait c'est fini
pour les quoi mais j'y lis je les ai
vendus les quoi mais ils m'ont dit c'est
bien quand même est ce que ce serait pas
l'esprit sain parce que c'est pour la
cathédrale s'il était là lui aussi mais
il est mais on ne sait pas où mais des
fois ça des pouvoirs insoupçonnés et une
semaine entière de labeur a été
nécessaire pour honorer la commande un
travail et qui lui a même apporté
d'autres projets c'est un chantier de
rénovation en fait agréable de paris
entier majestueux et dans un même temps
on travaille aussi pour une entreprise
qui veut direct du chemin de la protéger
mais est on à 100000 qu'à la faire
croître sur l'année l'école aussi
spécifique pour pour
khaled et déraille pas des rails de
chemin de fer des traverses c'est dans
la modernité parce que le bois sa place
à temps à réfléchir à sa place marteau
et forcément gilles durand s'est fixé un
objectif se rendre à paris une fois le
chantier terminé c'était le père du
village qui m'a demandé un hidjab on
pourra les voir ce chantier de la
cathédrale puis en même temps mais je
dis oui mais bon comme je travaillais
j'offrirai car ça sera pour tout le
monde payera le voyage et vous père vous
occuperez de nous accueillir but qui il
avait été sur paris mais on pourrait
aller coucher chez les soeurs et on
ferait un quart de la paroisse et noter
que gilles durand un carnet de commandes
étoffé avec ses fameux quoi en bois
notamment l'armée et les pompiers de
paris qui se fournissent donc depuis
cette scierie niché en plein coeur du
forez
direction la baie du mont saint michel à
présent dans ce grand vite et des
territoires là bas les pompiers
disposent d'un tout nouvel engin pour
secourir les victimes en mer un
aéroglisseur un véhicule étonnant vous
allez le voir monter sur un coussin
d'air et qui permettent aux secouristes
de circuler sur des surfaces d'accès
très difficile explication de la chaîne
tv air à rennes c'est un véhicule un peu
particulier qui vient de faire son
apparition sur la grande plage de
scherwey son nom l'aéroglisseur c'est
donc un moyen amphibie qui va nous
permettre de circuler à la fois sur le
sable la vase et l'eau et donc est
parfaitement adapté à la baie du
mont-saint-michel adapté car cette
machine innovante ne peut pas s'enliser
très utilisée dans les pays scandinaves
elle fonctionne grâce à deux moteurs on
a un premier moteur qui nous permet de
sustenter la machine donc de la levée et
qui nous permet de créer un coussin
d'air un coussin bien sur lequel on va
évoluer en fait le deuxième moteur qui
est derrière qui lui va nous permet de
faire tourner les listes est là derrière
moi et qui va propulser l'engin
vers l'avant avec une vitesse de 15 à 20
noeuds le véhicule permet de couvrir
près de 200 kilomètres carrés un gain de
temps considérable pour les pompiers
dans cette zone naturelle difficilement
accessibles dans la baie du mont saint
michel on a de la vase et que la vase et
20 on a des difficultés pour évoluer
avec des véhicules des véhicules à roues
on peut utiliser que des chemins il ya
une dizaine de chemin dans la baie du
mont saint michel le reste du trajet
pour rejoindre une victime se fait à
pied uniquement et
donc le secours se fait beaucoup avec
l'hélicoptère l'aéroglisseur est un
matériel de secours supplémentaire pour
les pompiers basée à dol de bretagne il
sera utilisé dès cet été qu à l'achat
70000 euros
les pompiers aux militaires vous allez
voir à limoges des collégiens ont
participé dans le cadre de leur
scolarité à une rencontre avec des
membres de la défense nationale
l'occasion pour eux de se familiariser
avec les enjeux de la citoyenneté et de
la défense et ce grâce à un jeu de
plateau réactions recueillies par
benjamin delmas de 7 à limoges sur place
par tour de jeu de plateau finalement
ils vont avoir des décisions à prendre
pour savoir quelles actions vont être
les plus efficaces ou pertinentes pour
pouvoir éradiquer les menaces auxquelles
ils seront confrontés à leur diplomatie
qui est représentant que le président
n'a l'euro le projection qui peut nous
sert à déplacer des troupes les élèves
de cette classe sont des élèves
volontaires qui ont choisi de suivre
cette option mais qui n'ont pas
forcément
l'envy d'en faire un métier ou du moins
pas encore
zoom à présent sur une belle histoire
dans ce journal c'est de george mourad
gens je me rate c'est un étudiant
libanais de 23 ans qui a décidé de
consacrer sa vie à aider les autres
après l'explosion survenue à beyrouth le
4 août 2020 au lit dans événement
tragique a poussé le jeune homme à
s'investir fondateur du marathon du
volontariat il s'est rendu en corse afin
d'organiser quarante deux missions
d'intérêt général pendant 42 jours et ce
dans 42 associations et qui peut devient
telle est pas aisé l'a rencontré lors
d'une collecte de denrées pour les
réfugiés ukrainien à l'île rousse
écoutez son témoignage récoltés par
dylan rouleau et gabriel pages
on accueille les jeunes qui ont le melon
donner quelque chose pour ces familles
on les accueille avec un grand sourire
on est là merci est tout simplement on
fait en phase avec éviter aujourd'hui
avec un grand plaisir bon parcours a
commencé après l'explosion de beyrouth
lorsque j'ai décidé de quitter la maison
quittée la famille et partir au chantier
de reconstruction pour pour donner pour
mon pays et pour essayer d'aider le
peuple qui étaient blessés après
l'explosion j'ai fait du bénévolat
j'étais chef d'equipe pour le 8e mois
consécutif
le bénévolat m'a changé la vie j'ai
grandi beaucoup j'ai expérimenté
beaucoup c'est là où je pensais à faire
un marathon de volontariat en fera le
tour de la corse sur les associations
pour donner un coup de main
voilà une bien belle action menée par
cet étudiant libanais en corse bravo
encore à lui dans les yvelines des
bénévoles et des collectivités
s'engagent aussi pour la bonne cause la
protection et la défense des chats
errants en france on estime à 11
millions leur nombre pour les aider la
ville de chanteloup les vignes et deux
associations viennent d'installer un
chat tipi une sorte de cabane celle-ci
leur permet de s'abriter vous allez le
voir un reportage de céline charles pour
tv 78 la chaîne les yvelines
le gîte et le couvert seront maintenant
offerts aux chats de chanteloup les
vignes à quelques pas du chapiteau de la
compagnie des contraire un petit
bâtiment aux allures de cabanes de
jardin trône depuis quelques semaines à
l'intérieur un foyer pour chats errants
ils sont nourris à l'extérieur déjà dans
un premier temps l'on voit ici avec un
système de récupération d'eau de pluie
ils ont également une première petite
cabane où ils peuvent s'abriter et puis
ensuite ils peuvent utiliser ce lieu
avec l'intermédiaire de deux trains qui
sont posées sur le latéralement sur le
lush atypique ça les abritent pendant
l'hiver quand il fait froid quand il ya
d'appui ou quand il ya trop de vent
c'est beaucoup plus agréable pour eux
comme pour n'importe quel animal d'être
à l'abri dans les eaux tempérées une
fois qu'ils sont rentrés à l'intérieur
vous avez ici à nouveau de la nourriture
protéger donc on a de chaque côté et
puis ils ont ici tout tout un tas de
coussins de lieux où ils peuvent
vraiment à l'abri et au chaud un
équipement offert par one voice une
association nationale qui luttent contre
l'errance féline et la municipalité de
chanteloup les vignes il vient compléter
les actions de l'association champoux
vaise sos matou créé il ya un an une
dizaine de personnes agissent au
quotidien on est là pour sauver les
chats errants déjà tout ce qui échappe
que ce soit avant ou même chats
abandonnés les stériliser
les identifier arôme est son terrain ce
qui a aidé à faire adopter le reste
quand c'est sociable ensuite il ya le
nourrissage un chat en bonne santé bien
nourris sera en bonne santé donc il va
développer - une maladie donc ça c'est
laid c'est le maillon dur si vous voulez
qu'il faut vraiment mettre en place et
là vraiment c'est le plus donc on est
ravi un peu de réconfort à défaut d'une
famille pour ses chats abandonnés
notamment après le confinement ou ses
chatons né dans la nature chanteloup les
vignes est la première ville des
yvelines a bénéficié de ce dispositif
la protection des animaux qui passent
aussi par leur contemplation via la
photographie dans la baie de somme le
festival de l'oiseau et de la nature
s'est terminée il ya quelques jours ce
rendez vous est l'occasion chaque année
pour des passionnés de photographie de
participer à des stages avec des
professionnels huit d'entre eux ont
notamment appris à photographier des
oiseaux en plein vol un exercice vous
allez voir difficile et qui nécessitent
de très bons réflexes jérémy houbron
pour ueo tv la chaîne de la voix du nord
voilà il faudrait apprendre maintenant
avoir le temps de voilà jean michel
lecat est un chasseur un chasseur
d'image c'est au petit matin quand la
lumière du soleil rase l'étang du crotoy
qui l'emmène huit stagiaires en escapade
repérer les oiseaux est une chose les
photographes hier en plein vol en est
une autre
là ça va là
la mouette on l'a su encore bien les
vanneaux tout à l'heure c'est
c'est plus trompeur dans le vol pas
facile d'immortaliser la parade nuptiale
des vanneaux huppés il faut être vif
déclenchée au bon moment assuré une
bonne exposition heureusement le
photographe animalier n'est pas avare de
conseils ne sont pas laisse de la place
tu as plutôt intérêt à dézoomer parce
que c'est donc pour trouver
depuis près de trente ans jean michel
parcours la baie de somme et
photographier les volatiles et great
spatule tadornes n'ont plus de secret
pour lui il connaît leur comportement
leur environnement des connaissances
indispensables à tout photographe on
sait par exemple qu'en ce moment les
vanneaux ce en pleine période de parade
nuptiale et quand on peut anticiper
cette période là
voilà on arrive sur des terrains où on
sait qu'il va y avoir du vanneau et on
sait qu'on risque d'avoir ce genre de
spectacle le spectacle se poursuit à la
réserve ornithologique de grands lavier
cachés dans les buts les photographes
observe les oiseaux dans leur intimité
on voyait bien en train de bouger de
remuer exactement comme il fallait il
était à trois mètres donc là pour la
photo c'est c'est le plaisir des yeux et
même rien que de le voir avec le
comportement comme ça sans être dérangé
il est libre une liberté parfois mise à
mal durant la pleine saison ces sites
d'exception sont pris d'assaut par les
visiteurs au détriment de la faune qui
les habite alors jean-michel profite du
stage pour rappeler les bonnes pratiques
beaucoup de porteurs d'eau tes objectifs
qui sont prêts à faire n'importe quoi
pour pour emmener le pour faire le
trophée de leur de l'oiseau avant tout
on est là pour respecter les animaux et
éventuellement faire une photo si c'est
possible sans lui nuire
après une journée passée suspendu au
chant des oiseaux viendra le moment pour
les stagiaires de visionner le fruit de
leur travail des centaines de photos
d'une baie de somme aux mille trésors et
ça ce n'est pas un cliché
partons dans le sud ouest pour la fin de
cette édition la cité du vin de bordeaux
accueille depuis le 15 avril une
exposition exceptionnelle consacrée au
thème du vin de l'alcool dans l'oeuvre
de picasso
l'artiste espagnol a multipliées tout au
long de sa vie les clins d'oeil aux
différents breuvages plus de 80 oeuvres
ils sont présentés avec des prêts
exceptionnels des musées picasso de
paris et de barcelone de quoi donner le
tournis avec modération bien sûr picasso
l'effervescence des formes une
découverte d'alix fourcade pour tv7 la
chaîne du groupe sud ouest
ne voyez surtout pas dans l'oeuvre de
picasso la seule évocation des plaisirs
de l'ivresse dans l'effervescence des
formes le peintre espagnol magnifie le
vin et des alcools populaire dans toutes
leurs dimensions le vin c'est un plaisir
de la ville c'est aussi un symbole de la
vie des forces de la vie' et puis
qu'elle soit toujours voulu intensifiés
cet aspect là l'existence dans son heure
à travers finalement toutes les
révolutions formelle qu'il a su susciter
créer et donc pour nous il y avait là
une conjonction entre la fonction du
lieu rappeler ce qu'a été le vin les
civilisations du vin nous sommes sommes
les héritiers et puis l'art de picasso
c'est aussi une culture qui rejoint son
catholicisme une culture qui rejoint
l'héritage des grecs le thème des
bacchanales
le thème des dieux est du genre des
dieux trois ans ont été nécessaires pour
rassembler les 80 tableaux et sculptures
de cette exposition elle montre la place
du vin et des alcools populaire dans le
travail du peintre grâce à des prêts
exceptionnels des musées picasso de
barcelone et paris et de collection
personnelle la cité du vin on a eu
l'idée un an après son ouverture
lors de sa première exposition
artistique en 2010 est la première
exposition qu ici qu'a proposé la cité
s'appelait bistrot et avaient d'ailleurs
une heure mais une seule une seule
oeuvre de picasso et l idée est née de
ce 10ème et finalement picasso a dû
faire il l'a fait beaucoup de choses
autour du vin et des alcools nous voilà
c'était un projet un petit peu fou qu on
est très content de voir se réaliser
aujourd'hui l'exposition est visible
tous les jours de 10 heures à 19 heures
jusqu'au 28 août
un concert pour terminer ce grand jt des
territoires mais un concert sous l'eau
serge teyssot-gay ex guitariste de noir
désir propose cette expérience inédite à
travers la reproduction de son naturel
pas de salle de concert donc mais un
voyage apaisant pour le public baigner
dans une piscine une découverte
rafraîchissante de l'est aurait bérol
pourvu occitanie regarder
vous ne l'entendez pas mais un concert a
bien lieu sur ces images pour l'écouter
il faut t'y merger ses oreilles
des sons venus d'ailleurs que parvient à
reproduire le guitariste serge
teyssot-gay transporte alors les
baigneurs normalement il ya une
sensation d'être en apesanteur les
dauphins les baleines parc en faire
mieux comme ça
en voyage
cette musique l'ex guitariste de noir
désir l'expérimentent la façonne avec sa
guitare et divers objets il reproduit
ainsi des sons issus des profondeurs
océaniques et de la nature en général
j'utilise les du bois du verre du métal
pour interagir avec la guitare c'est
super attirant 2
de répondre à des sons de la nature par
exemple pour essayer d'en créer qui sont
complètement subjectif je m'en amuse
dans la piscine dont il ya des oiseaux
qui se baladent incidents de ce projet
appelé immersion est menée en duo avec
un photographe à travers les corps des
nuits de gravité anthony j'en prends en
photo la musique de sergio les champs
sont complètement emporté par la musique
de sergio il se met dans des états de
transe
là j'ai vu monsieur pleurer c'est des
choses très très intenses je pense pour
eux et quand il pleut les gens s'y
mettre à fond plus et ces puissants à
travers toutes ces émotions qui
dégagement je vois la musique de serge
et c'est ça que j'essaye de prendre en
photo p les photos seront exposées dans
trois semaines à l'espace nautique jean
vauchère
voilà c'est la fin de ce grand jt des
territoires merci de nous avoir suivi on
se retrouve très vite pour une prochaine
édition au revoir à tous
[Musique]